well hello you're watching the press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages
coming up then we will see what's making
the headlines with the observer's chief
leader writer sonia soder
and the chief executive of conservative
home mark wallace great to see you both
as ever though to the front pages the
telegraph
suggests that july the 19th isn't really
freedom day given the government's
announcement that only on august the
16th will twice
vaccinated people be excused from
self-isolating
unless they themselves have curvit 19.
the ft says bosses are warning they
won't be able to cover
what they expect will be massive staff
shortages
if people are forced to self-isolate
after work from home rules are relaxed
and the guardian estimates that up to 10
million
could face the summer months in
isolation under the
newly relaxed guidelines that are
planned for the 19th of july
isolation insanity says the daily mail
again
referring to quarantine rules remaining
in place
until mid-august and the time
suggests new travel rules could be
ditched from as early as the 19th of
july
for those who are double jabbed
ahead of england's appearance in the
euro semi-finals at the mirror cheers
bring it home lads and with the headline
beer we go the metro estimates that 30
million pines
will be poured for tomorrow night's
match
well we're joined now by sonia soda and
mark wallace lots of maths going on i
have to say in the papers
don't mean the pints necessarily but the
number of people
who might have to self-isolate um given
everybody has to wait
with rising numbers of covert cases for
41 days for
these self-isolation rules to be relaxed
sonia what do you reckon
yeah the numbers involved are huge
aren't they so the guardian
is reporting tonight that up to 2
million people could get covert 19 this
summer according to government's
modelling and estimates
and because a lot more people end up
self-isolating
than are the number of covert cases um
that that could potentially mean
10 million people isolating over a six
week
period now obviously for businesses
for hospitality businesses for
restaurants um
kind of theaters cinemas etc
that's going to pose a huge challenge
over the summer
it sounds like the reason why the
government's decided
to bring in these rules these different
rules
later in the summer after july a few
weeks after july the 19th
um so people who are vaccinated will
still have to self-i
they get pinged by the app is because
the government's own modeling suggests
that
if they didn't have those um if they did
sort of change the rules from july the
19th
the number of cases could be even higher
so 25
higher and i think what the government's
done
and what its advisors have done is look
quite carefully
at what numbers forecast over the summer
and they
don't want them to go too high because
even with people with lots of people
double vaccinated
if you've got an increase in numbers
going to hospital that could put real
pressure on the nhs
so there's obviously some extremely
finely balanced judgments going on here
behind the scenes
yes the financial times uh lays out the
equation for us quite clearly
uh suggesting that recent data showed
that two people
are asked to isolate for 10 days for
every original case
suggesting that if 700 000 a week were
infected
a further 1.4 million could be asked to
self-isolate
in one week of course mark uh daily mail
calls it
isolation insanity a fury as quarantine
rules to last until mid-august
the problem i guess is that once you
announce something ahead of time
people start to they jump the gun don't
they you're already seeing
fewer face masks being worn for example
knowing that's
uh being relaxed come july the 19th so
will people already
or do they already ignore the the
pinging of the app
well i'm gonna say this feels like quite
a personal story for me i've just got
off a five-day
isolation from the from the contact
facing app i've got my second dose
tomorrow morning and i've got one of my
children
who's currently isolating at home so
well
exactly so you know it is disruptive
but you know a big part of this is
exactly the sonia says it's about
trying to gauge that balance and trying
to walk that tightrope
for example if i had ignored
the ping that i got from the app on
friday night and gone to
my planned second dose which was meant
to be on saturday morning
now mercifully touchwood i've got to the
end of the isolation without any
symptoms fortunately not to have covid
but had i had it unknowingly
and ignored that ping i would have taken
that virus to a vaccination center which
would have been even more disruptive
than just somebody having to stay home
for obvious reasons and so
it is about those those finely balanced
calculations and
one of the frustrations that you see in
the press in the papers tomorrow morning
is
understandably from businesses that have
been gagging to try to open to
get back to undo and recover some of the
damage that they've suffered
now saying now now facing some of these
extra restrictions and disruption
the the tricky thing is of course
remember just at the weekend the
alternative that people
some people were calling for was no
reopening for this to be delayed by
weeks further so it's a compromise and
it's gonna be a costly one but it's
it's a step back towards normality yes
daily telegraph then isolation rules
slam the brakes on
on freedom uh certainly we've heard from
the hospitality sector haven't we
suggesting
um that actually they've got such young
staff
um you know 60 of staff
age between 15 and 34. this is kate
nicholls
chief of the industry body uk
hospitality that
that so many of them um will not have
had the opportunity to have both jabs by
august the 16th that it threatens
openings for for many businesses
i think that's right and actually i
think there's a question about our
vaccination rates because they have
slowed down in recent weeks and
supplies of pfizer which is obviously uh
the the vaccine that
under 40s are mostly getting so that's
you know the
the groups are left unvaccinated at the
moment are reportedly quite tight
so i do think that that's a bit worrying
because we really just need to get
vaccines into arms as quickly as
possible
but but there are just very difficult
trade-offs here so i come back to that
statistic
around you know that the estimations
were
if the government dropped self-isolation
rules on july the 19th at the same time
that other things are opening up
you know infections could be 25 higher
over the following four weeks and we
have to make these trade-offs and
actually i think it's much much more
important
mark just mentions his children it's far
more important actually to prioritize
schools and if you're going to take a
risk on anything
the first thing we should be taking a
risk on is um children not having to
self-isolate
um uh in their butt if there's a case in
their bubbles because we know it's
incredibly disruptive to children's
schooling so
the whole story of this pandemic is
difficult tradeoffs and actually
to be honest i i really disagree with
the with the government dropping mass
being mandatory from the 19th of july
i actually find it reassuring that they
appear to have taken
the advice of scientists on these
self-isolation rules as tough as it may
be for businesses
yes i mean face masks um we've heard
them say multiple times
they're not saying don't wear them it's
just your choice when to wear them
when appropriately and obviously indoors
crowded spaces
um is is the key factor here um so the
guardian asking what happens if 10
million
face a summer of isolation and just on
that question of
vaccines dropping off mark is it supply
now do we know
or is it finding those arms to be jabbed
and we're going
going down the age range here and
clearly offering something
like self-isolation for those who are
double jabbed
is yet again an effort another carrot to
get
more more jabs into more arms
well it seems to be a mixture of these
different effects i've got to say if
you're looking at different things where
you might want to offer some kind of
to to you know balance different factors
to try and improve this
wall of vaccination vaccinated immunity
to prevent the
spread of the virus i think there's a
reasonable case for
giving people who are under 40 the
flexibility
to choose to take for example an
astrazeneca vaccine if they
are happy to do that particularly if
you're talking about a situation
where the spread of the virus is set to
accelerate
um you know that i i think you can have
things like that in the mix
you also see this announcement by the
mayor of london for example that he's
offering
effectively a lottery for people who
book their first doses in the next
couple of days to potentially get
tickets to the euro final
something we've seen in you know in
other countries um but
you know certainly my own experience
when i had to book another
uh another appointment a few hours
notice was that there was plenty of
availability
for slots of advisor for me at least
okay
um and obviously this new date of august
the 16th sonya has led many people to
query the news later on this week from
grant shaps the transport secretary
about this potential date of when the
double jabbed
could return from ambulance countries
and not quarantine
but the times uh it's it appears has
news
what do they say so they're saying that
actually it could be
you know all the speculation has been
that that the quarantine rules for
people returning from ambulance
countries would happen in early august
but actually the times is saying that
there are signals that it could be
earlier i think it is important to say
that it sounds like from the time
story i think that people would have to
take a pcr test
on arrival in order to avoid quarantine
now i imagine that that would reduce the
risks fairly significantly
um because i mean i think there's always
a danger that people coming in
to the uk double vaccinated maybe
carrying
um uh covered and and it might not yet
be registered on a pcr test but i think
it it probably does cut cut the risk
quite a bit
so it's perhaps not as um as sort of
risky or is even as free a policy as
people might have
thought it was from the way that it's
been reported um
but it is interesting the times are
reporting that it could be earlier
again it's an issue of trade-offs and i
suppose it will be because the
government
really wants people to be able to go on
holiday this summer
is it the right trade-off to be honest
it's really hard to say i think because
i think
a lot of the modeling behind these
decisions is quite opaque so it's quite
hard for some of us sitting outside
government to know whether the
government is actually making the right
decisions or not
and a number of the newspapers do
actually mention a trial a pilot
uh due to be announced um tomorrow
which will be introduced in which
passengers will present proof of
vaccination
at check-in and again on arrival back
into the uk the start of the start of
the process by the look of it
and the question is will any country
want us i guess
and this question of allowing cases to
get higher mark will no doubt
come before the prime minister before
the liaison committee um
what is the idea behind it the idea that
some of these cases that we will see
we would always see and better to see
them in the summer than in the autumn
this idea that the case is presenting
will be vaccine failure
or those who can't or won't have a
vaccine and therefore they are in some
degree inevitable
basically it just certainly seems to be
the case that my understanding just
about every
model of different timing and format of
unlocking has
some form of exit wave so you see some
kind of
uptake in the spread of the virus when
you
when you lift restrictions the question
is exactly what
scale that wave is when it is how it and
and how compressed it is in time
particularly in terms of its impact on
the nhs
i think the other thing we're seeing
certainly politically and socially
think of all the times in the last 18
months that all of us have had to
kind of rewire our assumptions and
expectations
as to what we expect with different
kinds of behavior and different kinds of
different stages in data for example
that that horrible learning experience
that we all had
um you know in in the early weeks and
months of this process
from seeing the date at which cases tick
up
then the lock step in which hospital
admissions and then the log step in
which deaths
go up in due course after a certain
period of time afterwards we all
went through the horrific experience of
learning that what we're now doing is
we're going through
just a difficult process which is trying
to
to kind of scry out and learn what
the rules are in the new situation with
covid not just the delta variant but
with mass vaccination
and that is that's something it is
difficult to learn is difficult to work
out but it's also difficult to shake off
and to leave behind some of the
hard-learned assumptions that we've
already
got who got going and that means that
pop politics is going to be even more
difficult to navigate
yes sorry to sorry to rush you um we've
got lots more to pack in
in the next part including this time
tomorrow night we will hopefully
know if england are through to the euro
final against
italy finally finished the game we'll
discuss the anticipation that is next
[Music]
sizzling was an amazing woman i had the
pleasure of speaking to her and her
family
around about october november last year
after the story that was done by sk
news the courage that the sizzling um
had to step forward and take that um
jump to take a career in police and you
know it can never be underestimated at
the time with rhesus riots
at the time with a number of other
things that were ongoing in it kyle's
speech
for her to have the courage to step
forward you know
it just it's something that that will
last forever you know and i'm so pleased
that she was recognized
because that recognition didn't come for
a long time and i'm so glad that she was
recognized before she did
pass away you know it meant a lot to her
to have that lifetime achievement award
from the national black police
association
and thankfully now um a lot a lot of
members have come forward to say that
the courage that you give them
to step forward and have that career in
policing um you know being a trailblazer
being the first person involved
in policing for black female that
that has really inspired you know
generations to come
i think she met actually underestimated
the impact that she would have on
policing and on communities at that time
you know she comes over as a nurse she
was a nurse before she came into
policing so she's always had that
current
nature and that current profession so
for me i think that's what motivated her
more than anything
obviously then um things changed when
she come in she when he started to
realize the impact that you had when the
press
were coming they are training in
different bits so so definitely about
making difference to communities about
care and then just helping others i
think was our main motivation
policing has come a long way from 1968
but unfortunately some of the challenges
with sicily nightlines
still impact our members today and still
impact those officers and staff members
from black asian minority ethnic
backgrounds
you know the challenges are still large
or not left we haven't quite
increased our representation as much as
we would like we're still only sitting
about seven and a half percent of all
police officers
come from a black asian or minority
ethnic background so
lots of work to be done and we're also
losing a lot of people because of
the kind of the culture is not quite
right at this minute in time but
lots of work still to do but i think the
contribution that sizzling has done in
the foundation that she's led
will allow us to push on and to try and
make those changes that are much needed
[Music]
i'm coming from a family of fishermen
actually my family from big fishermen
for five generations
the fishermen cut dispensed by accident
so we give them the motivation
and the system to bring it back to the
land we have collected already more than
110 000 kilos of plastic from the bottom
of the sea
[Music]
a few years ago my partner alex and i we
realized that there was a huge issue
with the way cleaning products are being
sold
[Music]
the family could only be bought in
plastic bottles and once used these
cheap bottles would inevitably break and
end up in landfill
since launching we've so far saved over
10 000
plastic spray bottles from ending up in
landfill
well welcome back you're watching the
press preview joining me sonia soda and
mark wallace we're going to look ahead
obviously
to what's happening on wednesday night
uh before we do that let's just show you
some of the very latest pictures from
rome bit of flash photography coming up
[Applause]
well celebrations as you can see not
surprisingly on the streets of rome
they're 1-1
extra time it went to penalties oh
goodness me 4-2 the result
so they of course the italians play
either
england or denmark uh are at the final
on sunday but the daily mirror
bring it home lads they say suggesting
that uh the pressure is on the squad to
end
55 years of hurt 55 years of hurt mark
my feet in denmark
uh no pressure on those uh young players
then
yeah but you know look at the pressure
they've already
they've already been under in the
performance they've already put in and
you know isn't it about time we made the
deal you know the poet laureate
um because it's coming home ah there we
go keep it simple
uh yes free posters in the newspapers
they come into it
into their own on days like this don't
they sonya um
is it gonna be an exciting time would
unifies the nation over
as the metro put it pints of beer too
well hopefully uh those scenes we saw in
rain we're gonna be replicated
uh here in england tomorrow night who
knows but i think it's quite hard to
uh top what mark just said there about
football coming home
but there are some brilliant stats in
the papers um apparently
6.8 million pints are expected to be
sold
and apparently sales of ties at t.m
lewin
up 350 apparently it's all inspired by
gary southgate's style
not the waistcoat this time well we will
wait and see won't we